brief word about the McGovern Institute
before I come on to the to the other
speakers in the agenda so we were
founded in two thousand in the year 2000
so we just celebrated our tenth
anniversary last year our mission we
were part of MIT and our mission here is
to try to understand the human brain the
brain in general both in health and
disease and although we're not a
clinical institution we don't we don't
treat patients here we do study them we
study brains of animals of healthy
humans and of human patients much of
that work being course done in
collaboration with with researchers at
local clinical institutions so we're
very excited to be doing this event
tonight as i mentioned it's the third
it's the third in a series of outreach
events to try to work with it to work
with disease advocacy organizations
we've done previous events on depression
and on autism and we'll be doing another
one on Parkinson's disease next month
that's the 20th October for those of you
are interested and we're delighted to be
working tonight with the Alzheimer's
Association and so I want to extend a
special thanks and special welcome to to
all of you who've come tonight and
particularly to nazia wherever you are
for all your help in organizing getting
their you out right and back thank you
so much much appreciated so anyway so
the McGovern Institute I won't tell you
too much more about it tonight and
you'll hear directly from two of my
colleagues fengxiang and John Gabrielli
I will introduce each of them in turn
followed by two speakers from the
Alzheimer's Association Risa Sperling
from from Brigham and Women's and
maritza maritsa dilla belt diliberto I'm
sorry okay I tried to celebrate I'm
sorry I practiced it once and looking
forward to forward to your comments and
then we'll open it up for general Q&A
and at the end I think that's about as
much as I need to tell you about the
agenda and i'd like to welcome
James Wesley who is the president and
president and CEO of the Massachusetts
New Hampshire chapter from Massachusetts
in New Hampshire Massachusetts yeah I
got it right and he'll say a few words
about the Alzheimer's Association so
thanks James Thank You Charles and and
we want to also extend our appreciation
Charles to you and your colleagues here
at the McGovern for allowing the
Alzheimer's Association to partner with
you and and on tonight's program I want
to do just two short things that
actually Charles asked me to sort of
said could I talk for just a second
about why is Alzheimer is important and
i hope i can do that and then i'll tell
you just ever so briefly about the
Alzheimer's Association by the way we
are have just celebrated our 31st
anniversary so we're very pleased about
that and our chapter the mass New
Hampshire chapter was one of the
founding organizations over the National
Alzheimer's Association but why
Alzheimer's disease and I'm sure every
every staff person with a different
disease organization will tell you why
they're so important but we we felt
pretty passionately about this cause and
and I'm sure that probably most of you
in the audience have either been
affected by Alzheimer's disease or
you're actually doing research to
hopefully ultimately lead to some
effective a treatments but just a quick
kind of a couple numbers there are 5.4
million Americans today with Alzheimer's
disease if we do not find effective
treatments by the middle part of the
century by 2050 we're looking at a three
to three and a half fold increase in
Alzheimer's disease it's a six leading
cause of death among Americans a
misnomer all language does not kill
people that's just not true and among
older adults it's a fifth leading cause
of death I am dead center in the middle
of the boomer generation and I'll let
you figure out how old I am but I'm
right right at the midpoint and they're
going to be 10 million boomers baby
boomers who will develop Alzheimer's
disease unless we can find effect an
effective treatment and you know that
this year the first of the boomers
started hitting 65 it's about one in
eight people over the age of 65 will
develop Alzheimer's disease and it's
almost half just under half of those
over the age of 85 will have Alzheimer's
disease so as this boomer generation
which is the largest generation in
history of humankind ages with age being
the greatest risk factor at least that
we know of today for getting Alzheimer's
disease we are just going to be
overwhelmed this disease cost hundreds
of billions of dollars and we're looking
at upwards to a trillion dollars by the
middle part of the century of direct
health care costs and so I can go on and
on but it's a really tough disease and
the other thing I want to mention about
Alzheimer's disease and I think it is it
is certainly true some of the other
neurodegenerative disease but I think
Alzheimer's is almost unique in the
impact it has on families so certainly
the elderly spouse not only has a
caregiving responsibilities but the
effect on their direct health is is just
extraordinary in fact the statistics on
elderly spouses is not good both in
terms of things like depression and
health and actually mortality as they as
their caregiving responsibilities
increase but this disease affects adult
children certainly my father had
Alzheimer's disease that affected myself
and my two brothers affects
grandchildren who there are just in
Massachusetts alone there are are
hundreds if not even up to a thousand
grant kids that are coming home every
day from school and taking care of a
grandparent while their parent is still
at work and and is not able to be home
so this disease really affects families
millions of American families today and
that's only going to grow so that's a
snapshot of why we care about this
disease we we really kind of look at
Alzheimer's disease frankly as third of
the the health disaster of this century
if we don't figure this out we are going
to be in deep trouble in terms of the
impact on people's health on their
pocketbook we won't have enough
caregivers we will not have an if we
could pay caregivers we will not have
enough caregivers to take care of 16
million Americans with Alzheimer's
disease by the year 2050 so I'll stop on
that but it's it's a tough it's a tough
issue and that's why the work of dr.
Risa Sperling and
and dr. Gabriela who's going to be spot
speaking for the McGovern Institute and
other colleagues here at McGovern and
actually people across across the know
the u.s. across the globe that work is
just so critical to us so let me talk
for another just a couple minutes and
then I will turn it back to you about
the Alzheimer's Association if you're
not familiar I like to talk about the 3
c's and I very of us succinctly I hope
which is care cause and cure and
ultimately we're here for a Cure on the
care side if you don't know the
Alzheimer's Association is really one of
these central places that the public
turns to for assistance we have a whole
range of services all of which are free
to families capital free we just in
Massachusetts New Hampshire we serve
probably 25 to 30,000 people year in
those two states and we're dealing with
hundreds of thousands of Americans every
year across the globe we are a national
organization so we can support families
anywhere in the United States of America
whether it's a 24-hour helpline or our
care consultation services education
program support groups really a wide
array of programs to help and assist
families and we also trained
professionals from whether it's a home
health aide coming into someone's home
all the way up sort of the professional
pecking order to physicians we do a lot
of our effort is actually trying to
educate and connect with primary care
doctors to they will they will screen
diagnose and then and then actually
prefer families and deal with the family
behind the patient with Alzheimer's
disease I'm very brief you so that's on
the care side on the cause side
everything I just said about how tough
Alzheimer's disease is another thing we
often say is that Alzheimer's disease is
one of the most important health issues
to which the American people have not
woken up to now I think that's changing
and I think the Alzheimer's Association
has been a part of that in terms of
raising the public profile media yewll's
you now see TV shows which a primary
character has Alzheimer's disease often
our national office in Chicago was an
adviser on that show to try to have that
as accurate as possible we so we do a
lot of work now in terms of the media
trying to connect you probably saw the
recently a pat summitt women's
basketball coach of Tennessee who just
announced that she had younger onset
Alzheimer's disease which we define as
under 65 i also want to mention
alzheimer's is not just an old person's
disease at least 200,000 maybe up to
400,000 people under the age of 65 have
alzheimer's disease and some of those
are in their 40s and 50s and in fact
we're going to hear from maritza she
talks about the diane study about a
particular subset of that I'll let you
do that but so we're so we're very
involved is trying to raise the public
consciousness and awareness of
Alzheimer's disease there's not nearly
enough money even even by the
Alzheimer's Association which I'll
mention in a second but by the federal
government that that is allocated to
Alzheimer's disease we are grossly
underfunded and in proportion to two
other major healthcare causes and we're
trying to change that and we will II see
ourselves as the movement to put an end
to this disease and I'll just mention
across the country and certainly here in
Massachusetts we have have a bunch of
walks we call now the Walk to End
Alzheimer's disease and it's not only a
fundraiser but it's our effort to really
mobilize the American people and just
here in Massachusetts in New Hampshire
in the next few weeks we'll have over
15,000 people walking to say this this
is an important issue and we want to put
an end to Alzheimer's so the last thing
I want to mention is cure that my third
C and we are very very committed to this
and where dr. Sperling is is really very
intimately involved with our national
research effort as well as a leader here
in Massachusetts collaborating with the
Alzheimer's Association we're the
largest private nonprofit funder of
research grants and certainly private
industry and the federal government is
much larger than us but just Nancy I
think which is about three weeks ago we
announced or for about a month ago I
guess we announced six researchers in
Massachusetts received just under nine
hundred thousand dollars worth of
research grants so every year we are
funding via International peer review
process grants to what we consider the
best and most promising researchers
across the globe we're very proud of
that record we'd love to
have more money to give out but we think
we do a good job with with with the
funds that we do have we also are very
involved and again dr. Sperling is
someone who's been quite quite active in
a number of other kind of collaborative
global collaborative efforts so whether
it's the alzheimer's association
international research conference that
we now put on annually it just was in
Paris no I did not get to go were you
there so yes see see the researchers get
to all the good places but the we there
are a number of kind of global
initiatives that really will probably
talk about the Alzheimer's disease
neuroimaging initiative and now there's
world Antony now this world Adney were
involved in genetics consortium there's
a entity called the research roundtable
that the Alzheimer's Association pulls
together quarterly which brings together
academics federal government but also
private industry and the intent is to
try to do everything we can to break
down some of those walls where industry
and academia and a federal government
aren't talking to each other because our
art what we care about is moving the
science and ultimately bring treatments
to market we what we're not concerned
about is who's going to win the Nobel
Prize for this we want to beat this
disease I know other people care about
that but our concern is with the
families that are living with this
disease so we're very proud of our our
role in doing our best to effort to
advance the science not only here but
also across the globe I will last thing
I do want to say is that we often say
Alzheimer's disease is an awful disease
but if you have to have it Massachusetts
is a good place to have it because we
have terrific diagnostic facilities
great physicians top-notch researchers
not only here at McGovern but also at
the academic centers here in Boston and
you can get among the best care for
Alzheimer's disease I certainly here in
a greater boston area then you can get
anywhere i'm at least in the United
States of America so that's a quick
overview of the Alzheimer's Association
again thank you so much for allowing us
to a partner with you here at the
McGovern Institute great thank you James
said was terrific I think
your comment about the being a member of
the baby boom generation certainly
resonated with me I realized for myself
when I wanted a volunteer for a brain
scan here and was told that I no longer
considered a healthy young adult I think
one of the things that that that has
been discovered in outsides research is
that this is a chronic disease that
begins years even decades before it
starts to manifest itself and one of the
things that we need to do if we'd have
any hope of treating it is to understand
that long progressive a long long
process that eventually leads to the to
the clinical disease and out feeling
here at the McGovern Institute of
scientists is that we're not going to
crack that problem either for
Alzheimer's or for any other any of the
other major of brain disorders that are
such such great afflictions without
understanding fundamental mechanisms and
James referred to the importance of
genetics and I think another things
that's been been learned both about
Alzheimer's and many other brain
disorders in recent years is the
importance of genetic risk factors as a
means to understand the disease process
and perhaps ultimately to identify
targets for further development of new
therapies and so that just really sets
the stage for our first speaker my
colleague Fang Zhang who is our newest
faculty recruits here at the McGovern
Institute Fung has a joint appointment
at the Broad Institute just across the
road which as many of you know is a
leading perhaps the leading center for
human genomics research and so it's
wonderful to have have Fang as a
colleague and to have this connection
between what we do here understanding
the brain and what they do across the
road in terms of understanding the
genetic causes of human diseases and
funds work is is very much focused on
that and on trying to develop new
technologies and new models for
understanding and maybe eventually
leading to the to the new treat to the
new treatments for these conditions so
an Phung I'll hand it over to you and
look forward to your comments thank you
yes
thank you for coming to hear my a
presentation I just started in January
so I'm see also getting used to this
place but what I want to talk to you
about today is is it's a set of
technologies that will enable us to
identify genetic basis for neurological
disease and i'll just start with this
introductory slide so the brain is very
complex it so if you I don't need
probably don't need to say this but this
is a picture of the mouse brain but if
you just take a cross-section of any
given area in the brain you see that is
composed of many different kinds of
cells these cells they have different
shapes they have different properties
they signal to each other in different
ways and and so because there are so
many different cells this complexity is
what enables the brain to carry out very
sophisticated functions that's how we
remember that's how we act that's how we
think that's who we are so here are just
some drawings of the cells so given this
complex system when something goes wrong
there can be very severe consequences so
here is just a list of some of the brain
diseases that affect a lot of us today
and what is common about these problems
is that we don't really understand the
cause the fundamental mechanisms of many
of these disease nor the way have
treatments for many of them so it's very
important to understand both the genetic
and the epigenetic basis for these
disease and so that's what I want to
talk about is how do I go about trying
to understand these disease so for many
many years the way that people have
studied this disease and the developed
treatment a lot of it is based on
serendipity so most of the most
effective drugs against psychiatric
disease are really discovered by
serendipity so lithium prozac so forth
and what we need is a more systematic
way of just taking a part of brain of a
diseased brain and to figure out what is
wrong and then by identifying those
mechanisms
we can then develop a treatment just to
target those exact mechanisms so the way
that we can take to reverse-engineer the
brain we can take a sort of focused
systematic way of taking apart different
components so if I give you a radio and
you try to figure out what is wrong with
the radio you may try to just take
different parts and try to replace it
with something to see if you can fix it
and that's how you go about identifying
what is what is wrong with their radio
and we're going to take a similar
approach to understand what is wrong
with the brain by trying to fix perturb
different parts of the brain to see what
fixes the problem now over the past
decade we have identified in many
different ways of sequencing the genome
and analyzing genetic differences
between different patients and so we
have accumulated large amounts of data
we now we now know there are specific
mutations that are highly correlated
with the disease but we don't know
whether or not they are actually causal
so are they the exact targets that we
can use to develop new treatment and
when you're new ways to allow us to
study those exact target and so we need
this technology new technologies to
allow us to functionally perturb what
that means is that we need ways to allow
us to affect the function of just a
single gene within the genome but also
we need these technologies that allow us
to introduce these mutations that were
identifying a human patient into animal
models so that we can understand what or
not these mutations are actually leading
to the disease so the way that people
have been able to perform these kinds of
changes perturbations within the the
cell or the animal model is using a
technology called zinc finger nuclease
so these are proteins that are not
naturally occurring their synthetic made
by human to target specific DNA
sequences on the genome and the idea is
by designing these proteins to target
only to the site where we find a
mutation we can then make a cut and then
repair the cut region with the correct
DNA sequence
so if we identify a cell that has a
mutation that's that's sort of inferred
or that that's a correlated with the
disease then we can try to fix this
mutation and see if in the repaired cell
the cell no longer has the disease
condition but this technology is very
expensive and if you collaborate with a
company to develop the technology can
cause up to twenty thousand dollars just
to fix a single site for your study so
we need a much cheaper way so that we
can study many of these mutation sites
at the same time so back in 2009 a
protein from this microb organism called
xanthomonas was identified and this
protein is very unique it looks like
this what in the middle of this protein
is a region of sequence that can be
changed that allow you to target this
protein to any DNA sequence that you
want to target so basically each one of
these red rectangles specifies for a
single DNA base that it binds to and you
can change the base that this red
rectangle binds to just by changing a
sequence of that protein and so so we
developed this technology for
applications to study diseases where we
take the natural protein and then we can
insert into the middle these regions
just like with lego pieces each one of
these modules will target a single base
and by putting them together in a
specific order you can dictate the
protein the DNA sequence that that this
protein is able to target so basically
if you want to target this DNA sequence
TT I actually can't read it anymore but
you just put in red red blue red and so
forth and that will tell you that will
allow this protein the anchor exactly to
the right position so using this
technology now we can engineer these
proteins to anchor different enzymatic
groups to regions the genome so for
example if a mutation or
regine is implicated in a disease and we
know that gene is either turn on a lot
or turn off a little bit then we can
anchor protein to this region and try to
rescue that so if the gene is low we can
turn it back on if the gene is too high
we can turn it down and by doing that we
can see whether or not we can rescue the
disease and if we can rescue it then the
bad gene that were targeting is the gene
that that's a worthy therapeutic target
likewise we can introduce mutations
directly into the DNA sequence by
designing two of these proteins and
making a cut so it works in exactly the
same way as the expensive technology
that I told you about earlier we can use
this very expensively to make a lot of
targeted mutations within the genome so
we tested whether or not this technology
works and basically we have we now have
a pretty robust system where you can
design these proteins to target any DNA
sequence you want and you can also use
this gene these proteins to activate
genes from the endogenous gene oh so
this now enable us to turn on or turn
off genes to study their function in DC
setting and then finally we have
developed a system so that you can
actually you can indeed use it to
introduce mutations within the genome so
that you can study whether or not by
changing a mutation you're finding at
the patient whether or not that can
rescue the disease state so so this
technology now provides a platform upon
which we can develop new your models to
study both the genetic basis as well as
the environmental influences that
contribute to disease progression so by
making these designer proteins we can
either modify the genome to generate
animal or cell models that we can use
the develop drugs but also we can use
these tales to modify the epigenome to
stimulate sort of environmental changes
to the way that cells behave and see
whether or not we can identify novel
targets in that
way too so I just started the lab but
i'd be very fortunate to be able to put
together a small team of students and
postdocs to to work in this direction
and hopefully in the next couple years
we can have some exciting result to
report back to you we hold the Q&A until
all four speakers of spoken and so I mec
speaker then is Professor John Gabrielli
another colleague of mine here at the
McGovern Institute John is the is a
factory member in the Department of
brain and cognitive sciences and he is
also the director of the Martinez
imaging center here at MIT and John is
involved in a very wide range of studies
imaging the brains of children and
adults healthy and diseased including
aging and alzheimer's disease as he will
now tell us so John
stay
thank you very much
good evening it's a an honor to speak to
this audience this evening and share
with you a bit of the work that we're
doing on buttons that usually move me
forward aren't sir yeah
oh that's just wrong that's okay but
when I do this huh okay thank you sorry
about okay now you're gonna quite
worried about the rest of my claims and
technical promise to do research of any
kind at all but I have the privilege to
work at the McGovern Institute and
thanks to the to the leadership in that
Institute and the Friends of that
Institute we have a remarkable brain
imaging resources downstairs from here
in one place really all the tools that
are available for non-invasive brain
imaging MRI m-e-e-e-e-e-e G and various
aversions of those in a single location
and we're very grateful for that chance
to work on research and so you know many
of you know all about Alzheimer's
disease the shrinkage of the brain that
occurs with the injury the plaques and
tangles that are the neuropathology
hallmark of the disorder the fact that
I'm post-mortem analysis the most severe
injury on averages in the hippocampal or
medial temporal lobe region and you can
see in vivo imaging here's an mr scan
here's a healthy hippocampus in an eight
year old and here's the withered
hippocampus and the other than other
forms of a cortical degeneration and a
patient with Alzheimer's disease and so
on as Charles mentioned and I think
you'll hear more about this by
everything we understand by the time an
individual receives the diagnosis of
Alzheimer's disease there's been
profound brain injury and that's very
hard to treat we were so far from
treating even milder versions of brain
injuries but that much injury is hard to
imagine at the moment what kind of
treatment would be successful so the
overwhelming research Shepherd in many
directions in many ways on humans for
the last decade perhaps I spent retire
roll back time and discovered the roots
of the disease and to discover its
earliest stages when treatments might be
more effective and a sort of important
idea and this is idea of mild cognitive
impairment there's debates about exactly
the best way to define and think about
it but in general it's the discovery of
increasingly effective ways of
identifying people who are not having
Alzheimer's now but are likely to have
it in next few years so sort of a
prodromal stage
a path towards the disease and a
striking thing is that I'm postmortem
studies these patients with mild
cognitive impairment so they do not
reach diagnosis for Alzheimer's disease
or dementia have a lot of written injury
already so here's a post-mortem study
some years ago looking at a cellular
volume in the n-terminal cortex the part
of the medial temporal lobe that seems
the first struck in most cases of
Alzheimer's disease and one can see in
this post mortem example that by the
time that person is mild cognitive
impairment before they passed away they
already have a lot of rain enjoyed in
case by this measure in this part of the
brain as much as a person with fully
diagnosed Alzheimer's disease so this is
the kind of direct evidence from the
brain that mild cognitive impairment
already has so much brain injury even
before the diagnosis of Alzheimer's
disease so a question that could be
asked is this we all dream of the kind
of studies that might come out from the
prior talk which is you know the
discovery and molecular neuroscience
that will just give a treatment they'll
rescue people that's the dream and that
has to be worked on but we can also ask
whether things can be done that might
slow the progression of the disease and
enhance people's quality of life I you
know until that thing until that miracle
we hope for arrives and so one question
we were interested in in many people are
is to what extent is the brain plastic
enough once you have mild cognitive
impairment how susceptible is it to
enrichment that lets you stave off the
consequences of the disease given how
much physical injury there is can there
still be a lot of recovery and
recuperation and I'm going to summarize
for you very quickly fairly recent
studies looking at physical exercise and
then cognitive exercise and I'll tell
you a bit about a small study we did in
this area just to sort of update you I
think we're that field stands in turn
i'll only report to you randomized
control trials so these what's common in
what I'm about to tell you our studies
people were randomly assigned there was
active control condition and everything
has been peer-reviewed and I mentioned
that to you because I'm especially the
cognitive exercise area you may know
that there's many companies who will
take your dollar with completely
unproven products and most of most of us
think it probably doesn't do any harm
but we're shocked about how the lack of
rigorous research in the area is a fair
okay so I'm only showing you things that
meet a reasonably high standard of
science um so here's a study that was
published us this year the Proceedings
of national academy of science from
ericsson all that took 120 adults 60 of
those were assigned to aerobic training
62 stretching exercises three days a
week seven weeks up to 40 minutes
procession so it's a fair bit but it's
not you're not in the gym all day every
day and then they examine both their
hippocampus the size of it and also
people's memory performance and what
they found was this that those people
who did the aerobic exercise and not the
stretching actually grew the volume of
their hippocampus these are these were
not people with MCI these were people
who are in healthy aging but that
physical exercise does that end the
people who were doing the mayor
stretching there was a mild decrease in
the volume of the hippocampus as if just
typical aging was going on the
stretching was not helping and it was
pretty brain-specific because other
parts of the brain the basal ganglia of
the thalamus did not show an exercise
induced green gain and volume
furthermore they gave them a test of
spatial memory and for those individuals
who had the aerobic exercise the the
more the hippocampus grew the more their
memory score improved as well these are
our giant gains I mean going to have to
think and this is a big step about how
this would apply to activities of daily
living for people but it's a it's a clue
that that might be a productive
direction and consistent with that there
was a physical exercise study in
patients with mild cognitive impairment
so these are people on average heading
towards Alzheimer's having on average
neural Alzheimer's related
neuropathology most likely in their
brain the study had 33 adults with mild
cognitive impairment again aerobic or
stretching four days a week now six
months and about 45 to 60 minutes per
session and the data are a little bit
complicated but the core findings were
there were gains in the individuals with
mild cognitive impairment on multiple
measures of cognitive tasks and they
were most consistent good news if you're
a woman less good music
you're a man they were most consistent
in women whether that will turn out to
be you know an atypical finding or
something else to think about we don't
know you know so here's two studies that
suggest physical exercises is a
promising available you know widely
available thing that might be helpful in
slowing the progression of the disorder
then i'm going to show you one resolve a
very small one is a pilot study really
that we performed looking at cognitive
training again many claims in this area
very few substantiated in any scientific
sense and even this one has a very small
number of patients a sort of a probe to
see whether it's in the right direction
so in this study what we did is we had
people randomly assigned with mild
cognitive impairment either into an
active or a placebo control I'll tell
you what that is the people in the
active condition played a game from a
company called posit science but they
had seven computerized exercise decided
to improve processing speed and accuracy
and auditory processing so there these
are computer games and I think the one
thing that people have agreed upon is it
Alma it's not clear that what game you
play matters a lot contrary to any any
vendors claim but i think the research
supports that having what's called an
adaptive design is probably important so
these computer games are set so that
you're performing at a certain level
it's meant to be challenging but not
hopeless and as you get better it
becomes a bit more challenging so the
idea is that for all the moments you're
doing it you're always in an area where
you're challenged but not hopelessly
defeated so you're sort of working at
your limits all the time and with
practice hopefully those limits become
larger the control group was also on the
computer but they were doing audio books
online newspapers and missed computer
games so at least they were on a
computer paying attention to something
for an equal number of hours as an
active placebo in that sense 90 minutes
a day on the computer five days a week
two months I can tell you that in these
kinds of studies nobody knows what the
right numbers are okay that you pick
numbers that you think people will
tolerate
and you know whether for months or six
months would be much more powerful we
just don't know so it's a challenge in
behavioral studies like these or
exercise studies to know what the right
dose and amount is in addition to the
looking at memory measures and these
individuals we also have people perform
a task while their brains were being
scanned with functional MRI where they
heard words and had to make judgments
about whether the words were concrete
like a table or abstract like love and
some were repeated in somewhere not I
won't go into the details but I'm glad
to answer questions so in a small sample
here was the finding that if we looked
at a test of memory the individuals who
had the active cognitive training
compared to the control showed a gain in
scores over time and the other
individuals for the Lawson scores and
people who are in a stage on average and
mild cognitive impairment you expect
such a loss there in a unfortunately a
downward degenerative direction on
average so so this is what you expected
a decrease over time from the beginning
the understudy but this group showed an
increase and when we looked in the brain
and this is a small number of subjects
for these kinds of studies but quite
remarkably and suggestively what we
found is exactly in the left hippocampus
left was a good debt because it's a
verbal task and left at the campus is
more involved in verbal memory on the
right and spatial memory a growth of
activation in those individuals who did
the cognitive training exercise relative
to the ones who did the placebo exercise
and so we could you can see it's right
here from three different perspectives
and the reason why it sort of worked
statistically in such a small number of
participants was that the results were
extremely consistent from individual to
individual so for the people in
experimental group five out of six
showed a growth of activation over time
for the people who had the placebo
control exercise that was an adaptive
that wasn't challenging them six out of
six all of them showed a decrease in
activation as part of the brain again
what we expect in the course of mild
cognitive impairment so if we asked is
there plasticity in the brain of a
person who already has a brain injury
with mild cognitive impairment on
average and there's some suggestion of
physical exercise can take advantage of
brain plasticity some further evidence
the cognitive exercise
take some advantage of you tissues to
gains and memory and gains in brain
function even in the injured hippocampus
even though the locus of the worst
damage there's a suggestion from the
imaging data that this plasticity that's
possible as game as possible and you
know whether combination of these and
other treatments would give this brain
plasticity that could support the
significant slowing of Alzheimer's the
significant gain and quality of life we
don't imagine we don't know but we don't
imagine this really stops the
neurobiology of disease but we might
imagine it gives people a longer time to
enjoy a higher quality of life and if we
have a number of these that add up that
could make a big difference as we wait
something to that makes a giant
difference thank you very much great
thank you John and our next speaker is
Risa Sperling great pleasure to welcome
her here to the McGovern Institute
research is an associate professor of
neurology at half a medical school she's
also the director of the research and
treatment on Alzheimer's disease at
Brigham and Women's Hospital and the
director of Alzheimer's the Alzheimer's
near imaging program at at Mass General
Hospital so and Thank You Risa and look
for your talk there we go perfect all
right thank you should I use them yes
okay great well thank you so much for
inviting me over here I get a chance
sometimes to come over to MIT and my day
job is actually trying to be a cognitive
neuroscientist so I'm thrilled to be
able to come over where it's done
particularly well but my heart job is
really trying to see how we might move
towards fixing Alzheimer's disease as a
clinician I'm a neurologist I treat
patients with Alzheimer's disease and a
clinical researcher so as you are heard
from John the field is really trying to
move towards earlier and earlier
identification of Alzheimer's disease I
agree that the last decade of research
has really been focused at the stage of
mild cognitive impairment
but the next decade of research and i
hope the last decade before we get an
effective treatment is going even
earlier than the stage of mild cognitive
impairment towards the stage that all
call preclinical Alzheimer's disease and
so the title my talk is really can we
detect Alzheimer's disease ten years
before dementia and of course the thorny
question why would we want to if there's
nothing we can do about it yet all right
so this is my analogous graphic to what
Alzheimer's diseases do we have a
pointer actually does this work um yes
okay oh thank you boy this is that a
full full service great okay I let's see
great all right so here are those 5.4
million individuals who are diagnosed
right now with Alzheimer's disease at
the stage of what we call Alzheimer's
disease dementia this right around where
you can see when the waves go up and
down is probably what we would call mild
cognitive impairment but unfortunately
this is the baby boomers and all of
those individuals who have the process
of Alzheimer's disease already beginning
in their brain and we know that this
begins 10 maybe 20 years before people
develop symptoms so this iceberg
unfortunately is looming towards us as
you heard from jim in terms of clinical
disease but this unfortunately is what's
already in the brains of individuals so
when i hear these statistics of 5.4
million i think unfortunately it's
really 30 million probably already have
the process in their brains so this idea
of preclinical Alzheimer's disease
really has taken hold over the past few
years because of the advent of
biomarkers and I'll show you some of
this so this is ways that we can look in
the living human for evidence of
Alzheimer's disease beginning in the
brain before they have symptoms and
evidence from both genetic at-risk
populations and from older individuals
who are completely clinically normal
already suggests that again the brain is
starting to have changes 10 or 20 years
before the point that they get to the
stage of Alzheimer's disease dementia
this is a glass half full glass half
empty this sounds horrible all these
people of the disease beginning in their
brain but it's an incredible opportunity
if we could identify these people to be
able to start treatment before they get
symptoms and ultimately even if we can't
prevent the disease in the brain perhaps
we can prevent the dementia but we've
got a lot of work to do over the next
decade to prove that and I'll show you
some of our work in this area so this is
another way of showing it again a
continuum of Alzheimer's disease this is
the stage of mild cognitive impairment
or prodromal Alzheimer's disease and
this is the decade before it now some of
these individuals are completely
asymptomatic but the harder we look and
I'll show you some of these data you see
that individuals have changes that go on
that are very very subtle before they
get to the stage of MCI and as a
clinician it's so common when I see
someone in my office and I asked them
about when did you really notice a
change they say oh yeah actually five
years ago at the Christmas party I
realized this and you can even
unfortunately sometimes look at their
checkbooks back and when people used to
use checkbooks and see these errors that
started to happen in the checkbooks two
or three years before they even get to
this stage so the question is how will
we identify these people who are on this
tipping point because that would be a
very good place to treat so a lot of
work as i mentioned been done in the
field of biomarkers and we now have ways
through imaging through spinal fluid and
some blood tests to be able to identify
changes that are occurring in the brain
a lot of this work is really focused on
something called amyloid many of you
probably heard about this these are the
plaques that are thought to accumulate
in the brain this is a protein we all
make normally but in Alzheimer's disease
it appears to accumulate not only into
plaques but in these small soluble forms
that appear to be toxic to nerve cells
and again the evidence both from our
group i'll show you as well as multiple
groups around the world suggest that
amyloid goes up at least a decade before
the first symptoms of Alzheimer's
disease and a lot of this work you'll
hear about has been from autosomal
dominant mutation families which are
here about from a very personal
perspective from maritza
but again this is also the case of older
individuals who don't have a genetic
respecter and then we have multiple
other biomarkers that are able to look
at brain functions so you heard about
one functional MRI or fdg-pet and we can
also start to look at other proteins in
the spinal fluids such as tau which is a
marker of neuronal injury and again we
know that this is occurring about five
years later after amyloid is starting
but still five years before you start to
get significant clinical symptoms now
when we started to put forth this idea
of preclinical Alzheimer's disease there
was quite a bit of a backlash less I
don't know if you saw some of the news
last year when we put forth these new
criteria you know why would you think
about Alzheimer's disease if you
diagnosing somebody if you can't do
anything about it and how do you know if
they'll get Alzheimer's disease and I
agree that there are a lot of thorny
issues we still need to work on however
if you look around at the other diseases
where we've made progress in cancer in
heart disease in diabetes all of these
we do well because we treat before
people get symptoms in fact when I look
at the drugs that are successful in
really treating something all of them
are really most successful at a
preventive stage the only drug i think
maybe that's an exception is viagra
where symptoms might be required for
treatment but everything else really are
advances in medicine have been made by
going earlier and we just simply have to
change the paradigm in alzheimer's
disease and move to this earlier stage
again we don't require symptoms to
diagnose other diseases you go all the
time and get a blood test to see whether
you have evidence of kidney disease or
liver disease and if you treat the blood
test or the abnormalities you can
sometimes prevent the symptoms from
occurring now importantly of course this
doesn't mean that everybody who has a
risk factor or amyloid beginning in
their brain will go on to develop
Alzheimer's disease dementia we don't
know some people would be hit by a bus
some people have very resilient brains
and may never succumb but that doesn't
mean we shouldn't treat at a population
level just like we do for cholesterol or
other diseases
alright so we came up with a staging
framework with an idea of how we would
identify individuals in these very early
preclinical stages of Alzheimer's
disease in particular so that we might
be able to begin clinical trials and
I'll come back to that so individuals
who already have amyloid evidence of
neurodegeneration and in particular if
we can look hard enough evidence a very
subtle decline these individuals we know
are very high risk of moving to mild
cognitive impairment and on to ad
dementia over the course of two to three
years so one of the techniques we have
for doing this is using pet imaging so
the moloch there's a molecule that
actually is used when people used to die
and we used it at autopsy to identify
Alzheimer's disease and some very smart
people at Pittsburgh tagged this marble
molecule and you can now use it in
living humans to detect amyloid plaques
in the brain and so this is work from
our group but again multiple groups have
already shown this the vast majority of
Alzheimer's disease patients already
have very elevated levels even at mild
stages of the disease when you look at
mild cognitive impairment you see it's
about half and half about half of the
individuals already have a full
complement of amyloid very similar to
Alzheimer's disease patients the other
half don't we don't yet know whether
these individuals will develop
alzheimer's disease dementia the
originator that's come out so far
longitudinally suggests that if you've
got amyloid you have a seven to eight
higher fold higher likelihood hazard
ratio of moving to ad dementia so it may
be that these individuals will never
move on to Alzheimer's disease dementia
but the work in our group is really
focused on these normal older
individuals these are people who we
screened perfectly we were certain they
were normal and about a third of them
already have evidence of amyloid up at
the levels of Alzheimer's disease now
this might sound very surprising but in
fact 25 years ago they did autopsy
studies and noted that about a quarter
or a third of normal older individuals
when they died again over the age of 65
or 70 had changes of alzheimer's disease
in their brain and this has been part of
the conundrum how can it be you can walk
around with a head
full of amyloid and not have dementia
this is the cause or at least an
important part of Alzheimer's disease
but if it actually takes 10 years to get
from here to here and we know that again
a third of older individuals have
amyloid and a third of people a decade
later will be diagnosed with Alzheimer's
disease dementia maybe this is really
just preclinical disease all right so I
promise because of John Gabriella's here
and this would be bringing coals to
Newcastle I'm not going to show any fMRI
data functional MRI data but I will tell
you that using functional MRI we can
identify that there are brain changes
and people not just at the stage of mild
cognitive impairment but in individuals
who are normal based on the basis of
whether they already have amyloid in
their brain or not and these changes are
very often occurring in this same
network which is vulnerable to amyloid
and is very strongly functionally
connected to the hippocampus that you
just heard about from Jon and
interestingly we now have a new project
where we also take spinal fluid from
these individuals who have these
functional changes put it back at a
cellular level and we can see that this
impairs long-term potentiation or the
synaptic plasticity at a molecular level
so now this is terrific because we have
the ability potentially both at a
molecular level even at an electron
microscopy level or at least at an ultra
microscopic level to be able to see
these changes in the brain and then go
back and ask whether we can see these
changes in life and whether changing
with the therapy would improve these
functional and structural abnormalities
I won't let me go quickly past this
because I'm sorry this is actually two
some work showing also that if you look
hard enough these people who have
amyloid in their brain they don't just
have functional changes if you do memory
tests even though they're still within
the normal range they perform below
their amyloid negative peers all right
so one important thing about this is
that it probably depends where you start
this is Superman in his later years and
again it's important that we think about
where a person's cognitive reserve a
brain reserve so maybe some people are
better able
withstand the effects of amyloid because
they're smarter and in fact coming to
lectures like this at night I'm sure is
improving your cognitive reserve so I'm
just going to spend one minute on this
last part which is treatment of
Alzheimer's disease right now we have
drugs that really treat the symptoms and
we don't yet have a disease-modifying
therapy and the question is how do we
get from the drugs that haven't shown
much promise yet at the stage of mild to
moderate alzheimer's disease to ice a
useful disease-modifying therapy the
need for early intervention again you've
already heard a bit about this from John
but importantly we've had multiple trial
failures maybe we don't have the right
drugs maybe we don't have the right
target but another possibility is that
we're just trying it too late in the
course of the disease so this is a paper
that came out last year in which a
monoclonal antibody to amyloid was given
to humans and we saw just like we'd seen
in mice that we were already able to
remove amyloid from the brain with this
monoclonal antibody of treatment the
problem is that even though again we
were able to reduce this compared to
placebo we were not able to demonstrate
any clinical change at the stage of mild
to moderate dementia and I think this
for a lot of us was a big wake-up call
again maybe Emma Lloyd isn't the problem
but maybe we need to be treating a
decade earlier if we want to make a
difference and again this is why this is
a person who already has very mild
Alzheimer's disease but they've already
got an extremely shrunken hippocampus
shrunken brain I think we could suck all
the amyloid out of the brain but until
we can really regrow nerve cells we're
not going to be able to stop the disease
if we start at this point so there's
this urgent in my opinion I hope that
greatly that the trials that we're doing
now at mild cognitive impairment stage
and very early Alzheimer's dementia will
show us a signal of efficacy but
ultimately I believe we're going to have
to treat a decade earlier than we
currently are and there are already a
number of these efforts ongoing you'll
hear about 14 maricia the dominantly
inherited Alzheimer network trying
trials and individuals who have a
genetic predisposition to Alzheimer's
disease and a secondary
trial which I hope will start next year
which looks at amyloid positive older
individuals over the age of 70 and we'll
try some of these biologically active
molecules likely a vaccine or an
antibody to say if we can change an
amyloid before they have any symptoms
can we delay the onset of symptoms by
following these individuals for three to
five years and I think although we'll
probably need many of these trials this
is a chance for us to really move the
paradigm so I will I know other people
will ask you for financial support and
other things and I think that's great
but you can do something even besides
donating money which is participating in
research in clinical research we need
people who are normal we need children
of people who have been affected by the
disease the real bottleneck right now in
alzheimer disease is not that we don't
have good treatments in someone's test
tube the real bottleneck is trying to
figure out whether they work in patients
and families who are willing to give
generously of their time so I will
highlight the Alzheimer's Association
trial match which is a way you can go on
and see if there's any research anywhere
relevant to you anywhere in the country
and also the Massachusetts Alzheimer's
Association has research opportunities
this is our group at the Brigham and
Women's at Mass General Hospital and
also the ADRC and we hope that you'll be
interested in participating in some of
these studies thank you very much